m
mon dieu
oh
meetic qui ont fait des films qui
sauvent arabes ont débuté par le vôtre
son court métrage il aurait pas rennais
truffaut en écumant les tati chose je
suis pas mouillée fond de mon nom mais
un par exemple on joue jour de fête un
jour jouer le fait cinq courts métrages
ou pas les gens ne faisant un peu plus
chaud sujet pour ses promoteurs sur le
court métrage vous n'avez pas qui tu ne
voudrais pas chaplin on avait ce que
vous voulez entendre vos seins numéro un
en suisse
de la merde moi je préférais est ainsi
un peu moins confortablement d'une seule
main et de voir les enfants du pareil
que deux casiers dans un fauteuil de
dentiste on s'enfonce
quand on enlève il ya des fauteuils aux
champs-elysées qui sont chargés à peu
sur un prochain les gens pètent
quelle est la raison du l'a descendu en
flèche du court métrage et du cinéma
français je vous le dis c'est une
question commerciale puisque les
distributeurs interdisent le passage des
courts métrages ou passer les fils
publicitaires bon alors est-ce que vous
jacques tati vous avez une solution
proposée je prends deux pour sa part 7
1% sur les eskimos diminue mais c'est
très facile 6 ou 9 parce que moi qui ai
vécu une période où dans les cafés via
vient d'y impopulaire si vous les
critères remplis d'imagination enfant
dieu populaire fort bien fini par tout
ce qu les 11es jambes ne se sont jamais
autant envers des grands sombre et
d'après vous donc il ya des retombées
sur le site auto mais plus spécialement
ceux générale les français se garde bien
ri sur le plus fort c'est pas toujours
même rôle alors on s'imaginer en france
qu' il faut moins de travail et on vit
dans un pays sérieux et à 300 fromages
vosges les nouveaux vins victoire au
bout bien on s'installe et on va dire a
renchéri sean troisième ménisque de joie
le plus marrant visiteurs s'intéressent
à moi j'entre toujours milité à culture
quand même trop tonnes et ça fait trois
fois que c'est plus le même ministre
ben non je m'en fous je dis ce que je
pense
ça plaît ou ça plaît pas et jour vous
prennent six ont cas de mauvais titre
deux journaux du couvent du rire pour
vous ça sans parler des sujets de films
possibles bon jeu on pense qu'on va voir
si on retrouve que des français vivent
eux vivent moins bien sur les autoroutes
que quand ils étaient petits chantiers
de dessiner c'est pas moi je fais trafic
prévoit que je touche pas vraiment enfin
pour en revenir ou aux solutions pour
sauver le cinéma elle court métrage en
particulier vous avez rencontré il ya
peu de temps donc le ministre de la
culture
non mais j'hésite toujours en compte
tous les ans prenait bon il nous a
promis quoi il a promis qu'ils allaient
faire un effort ça fait longtemps qu'on
brin dorman aurait dû en faire un mail
était foutu à la porte avant qui chasse
aux maisons et le cas et le 15 à 20 c
alors mais moi je suis toujours l'avoir
pour moins cher
mais j'avoue que je ne lâcherai pas uson
premier les choses précises sur le long
métrage avec les x pressant et pensons
la provision dans la profession les
fidèles sont un peu vous savez j'ai un
peu ce genre
parce que quand on va demander à
truffaut bout du blé défend les chevaux
métrage répond mais monsieur moi je suis
très content que le tournage reste il
moi je si je pouvais aussi dire comment
montferrand histoire c'est le genre quoi
secrétaire du plaisir chez un enfant
j'ai juge garantie gave autre chose à
faire mais aujourd'hui main alors tout
le monde s'en fout un tel point que moi
autrefois dit les jeunes il se dégonfle
est beaucoup moins quand ils allaient
dans les salles dites union quartier
latin
s'ils avaient trop de place à issy flay
comment tu as projections étaient
mauvaises six étaient flous y siffler
ils sont venus au flottement à voir on
leur fait que c'était n'importe où mais
voilà je continue un chiffre de 38 à lui
vécu kokoïty a su charmer mars
parce que qu'on m'explique comment je
dois avoir rasé
je vais dit c'est quoi c'est toujours
pisté années 80 les choux et suit les
godasses et plusieurs ont mis du cyanure
les futurs ligue 1 bon ça n'arrête pas
de faire des bruits alors l'aider
ajoutez à ça le bruit que font ce doji
tout à l'heure les fauteuils d'orchestre
les salles très moderne où les fauteuils
d'orchestre de lâcher des gars gens
viennent très chiant
distingué
et il peut en saisir jeunes de chine a
un côté amusant
on
bon